now whether he's dealing with Foreign
Relations or our own Intel agencies a
Donald Trump is living up to what he
promised on the campaign trail he is a
disrupter when he believes it would
benefit America he's unafraid to
reorient or even challenge old alliances
and sometimes he'll opt toward building
bridges to old adversaries for the
greater good as he has on so many issues
Trump has ditched the PlayBook of the
bipartisan establishment and also the
conventional wisdom that goes along with
it and let's face it this has driven the
old guard in their cheerleaders
positively bonkers I just personally
think today is just an incredibly
depressing moment in in our time in our
history as an American when your home is
burglarized you don't invite the burglar
over to dinner you put in a home
security system we should not be
inviting President Putin to dinner at
the White House it's quite a pass we've
come to when the leadership of a country
like Iran seems more stable and rational
than the president of the United States
the US influence is diminishing and the
overriding thing that connects all of
this is diplomatic malpractice by the
president the United States diplomatic
malpractice diplomatic norms like what
are those are those the norms that allow
China to go virtually unchecked for
almost two decades or the diplomatic
norms that thought that Iraq was an
essential war or is it when we looked
into Putin's eyes and saw his soul the
fact is many of the same people trashing
Trump's disruptive approach were the
same ones who advocated the most
disastrous policies of the post Cold War
era of course as long as they hit the
president they're still gonna get cushy
gigs at the New York Times or that
Amazon paper and I would also get pundit
purchas at other cable outlets in other
words they get total immunity for being
perpetually wrong on critical issues the
good thing is Americans both on the left
and the right continue to reject the old
norms that led to job losses flatlining
paychecks offshoring our manufacturing
and
Aster's military interventions President
Trump has stood up to China with tough
tariffs while slapping severe sanctions
on Putin and also Kim jong-un and now
he's standing up at a moment of social
and economic instability for the regime
in Iran
typically his all-caps tweet advising
the Iranian president to never ever
threaten the United States again I was
coming back front trip yesterday like
whoa it's all caps it was greeted with
the same snark in skepticism of so many
of his global initiatives well the
difference this time though is there
seems to be coordinated communications
at play a strategy something the White
House I think is long-needed
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
national security adviser John Bolton
each sent out messages echoing the
president's Iranian stance now this is a
radically different approach from the
mixed messaging that followed the
Helsinki summit we talked about this
last week so but while he shakes the old
global order Trump is also rattling the
cages of the Intel community cages that
no one has ever dared to rattle remember
during the campaign when Trump spoke
about reforming and ending the
corruption at the FBI and the CIA even
his political nemesis sounded a warning
you take on the intelligence community
they have six ways from Sunday at
getting back at you so even for a
practical supposedly hard-nosed
businessman he's being really dumb to do
this and boy have they work to get back
at him and we now know that the
unverified Oppo research used to secure
those FISA warrants to spy on an
American and the FISA judges by the way
weren't told that Hillary specifically
funded it then of course we know that
rogue FBI investigators use their powers
as an insurance policy should Trump
actually be elected meanwhile some Obama
era Intel officials responsible for so
much of the deep state mischief have
become the critics in chief and today
the White House announced the
president's intention to strip them of
their security clearances
including former CIA chief john brennan
who last week called the president's
helsinki comments oh so subtly
treasonous not only is the president
looking to take away
Brennan's security clearance he's also
looking into the clearances of Comey
clapper Hayden rice and McCabe the
president is exploring the mechanisms to
remove security clearance because they
politicized and in some cases monetize
their public service and security
clearances okay well a couple of note
even have their security clearances any
longer it's good to check that before
you go out there and say that however
this disturbing episode I think it does
require more than security clearance
revocations it's bigger than that
it's about the credibility of the people
who are heading up our intelligence
agencies in their inherent political
biases the president should be
encouraged to continue disrupting on
behalf of the American people at home
and abroad contrary to the media
narrative a new poll shows that voters
are with Trump a new Wall Street Journal
NBC News poll taken before and after the
Russian summit reveals that the
president's job approval rating is up a
point since last month to 45 percent a
high for his presidency imagine if we
had a fair media among Republicans the
Trump has an 88 percent approval rating
other than I asked george w bush after
9/11 that's a higher intra-party rating
than every president since World War two
huh now President Trump is on the right
path but he must proceed cautiously and
react deliberatively always keeping the
focus on the American people they're the
ones who elected him the resistance will
seize on missteps and communication or
approach or in policy as proof that they
were right all along you got to leave it
to the experts mr. Trump but by all
means continue exposing Washington
corruption corruption and those who
profit handsomely from it that's the
most enjoyable disruption of all and
that's the angle